So what did we achieve in this unit?
We found a differential equation that governs the motion of that spacecraft
around the earth and around the moon.
And we know a simple solution method to solve differential equations
on the computer--the forward Euler method.
But there is lots of stuff left for Unit 2.
We have to actually solve that differential equation,
and it turns out the forward Euler method isn't quite the method to be using.
We have to actually solve the differential equation by computer.
And it turns out the forward Euler method is somewhat too simple for that purpose.
And of course, we have to eventually find a trajectory that's going to bring Apollo 13 back to earth.